um then we've got a little bit more time
let's see who's on the phone from the
two-five to area code two five two
please jump right into your question oh
hello hi we're not on speakerphone are
we no good oh not again um I just I just
have to ask you this because I saw a
linear one the videos talking about you
and home
yo you're Chris's and seminary and and
here's my question to you because I
didn't really understand it because it
was kind of easy you said that that you
know Sam Harris was a historical because
he didn't talk about the the the
so-called Muslim Golden Age but my
question to you is how is that relevant
to you today it ain't there it's a I
think you might have misunderstood my
commentary no it's relevant to today
only in understanding that what is
taking place with Islam today is not
something that has been the sort of norm
among major religions for the history of
those religions right there there's no
denying whatsoever right like on it's
just just math that right now the
majority of terrorist incidents around
the world are with perpetrators that are
adherence to the most Muslim religion
but I think it's relevant only in
understanding that this is not a
historical inevitability and it's not
been a historically persistent thing
that there were errors in history not
that long ago where the violence was
disproportionately coming from
Christianity and it's just a relevant
thing to under it's relevant in that
it's part of the historical context and
that we should see what's taking place
currently in Islam as a problem to be
dealt with that is going on right now
but not a sort of systemic and
historical problem that has pervaded all
of humanity that's the way in which it's
relevant okay yeah I mean um I you know
I know like Chrisman history you know
fishness have been like very terrible
and most of it most of that is due
- you know we in the West are more aware
of Christian history yeah then we are
whether many other histories like that I
think that the you know my thing is cuz
I know you I know you're not because you
know there's some people that think
you're regressive right I don't think
you're aggressive I really I know you I
know you own you really criticize Islam
which which is good there's you know a
lot of people unfortunately that call
themselves progressives don't do that
right it's just that you know I just
want you to clarify that for me cuz oh
no David no maybe I misunderstood well
my pleasure I'm able to clarify and I do
want clarity this evening and and I do
appreciate that thank you for the call
great to hear from you again sorry we
didn't get to everybody who's holding
but we will try again next week quick
break back after this